the Trump administration is proposing
low-cost health insurance alternatives
to Obamacare and Democrats do not like
it at all now the plan would allow
health ensures to sell short term
policies with lower costs and fewer
benefits Democrats immediately ridiculed
it as junk policies trash garbage
Senator Chuck Schumer released the
following statement since day one the
Trump administration playbook on health
care has been to sabotage the
marketplaces jack up costs and premiums
for millions of middle-class Americans
close quote
joining the angle exclusively to explain
the proposal is the new Health and Human
Services Secretary Alex azar mr.
secretary thanks for giving us the first
interview great to see you
so boy the blowback you guys are getting
for offering an alternative is wild
Nancy Pelosi says Americans purchasing
the shoddy misleading short term Trump
care plans will be one diagnosis away
from disaster etc etc in other words
it's Armageddon the shocking thing is
these plans were in fact available until
October of 2016 during the entirety of
the Obama administration's tenure now
we're bringing them back they got rid of
them at the end of the administration
and said you can only have these plans
that were three months they cut them
down to three months and they don't have
any of the Obamacare restrictions in
terms of the mandates from the central
government it lets them be flexible so
people can get lower cost plans if they
choose to yeah so now now you're in
these plans that are supposedly health
insurance but it's not really it's it's
access but you don't people don't go to
the doctor as much because the
out-of-pocket costs are so high the
deductibles are so high I keep hearing
this from my radio listeners who call
and say like Laura I got it I have
insurance but it's $3,600 before I can
take advantage of it is that are those
people like kind of the middle class
that we're stuck in that that area of
the the economy or they're gonna best
benefit from this so we think a couple
different groups of people could benefit
from this first there are people for
whom the Affordable Care Act Obama cares
individual insurance plans are simply
unaffordable you know premiums
doubled before the end of the Obama
administration so individual market
premiums have soared so for many people
the plans are not affordable to get and
what they get may not be real insurance
and good enough in terms of that kind of
high deductible you're talking about so
for some of those people these less
expensive plans often one-third the
price of Obama care plans might be a
good option for them so pre-existing
conditions what happens
so these plans don't have those Obama
care mandates around pre-existing
conditions don't have to accept if you
have they don't okay I have lung cancer
take my so first case so for somebody
like that other options would probably
make more sense but for other
individuals these may be the cheaper
young options young people healthy
people that are already being shut out
of the Obama care marketplace cuz of
that cost high cost because the way the
plans were structured the premiums are
so high for the young and healthy
they've already been driven out of the
marketplace you know our opponents on
this talk about this as if as if we're
right now living in the land of milk and
honey and everything is perfect and
nobody has lacking insurance we're
talking about the 28 million Forgotten
men and women who do not have insurance
that were promised affordable insurance
and President Trump with his executive
order demanded that we come up with
solutions and options like this for
affordable individualized health
insurance guys you're just trying to
kill off Obamacare that's there you're
trying to kill it off and America's
health insurance plans a big industry
trade group they said we remain
concerned that expanded use of short
term policies could further fragment the
individual market which would lead to
higher premiums for many consumers
particularly those with pre-existing
conditions now why are they so upset
about this mr. secretary
well the National Association of
Insurance Commissioners isn't it was in
the past very supportive of these
efforts to increase these affordable
options for people we're trying to just
make options available for folks who've
been shut out of the marketplace now we
need to keep working to build a
different system than Obamacare but
while we have it we need more affordable
options for people to get the insurance
they want not what I tell them they
should have like why should a 55 year
old man who's unmarried have to pay for
birth control in his policy like why is
that something that what we want to we
want to have make a system where people
can buy the insurance that they want now
we need to work with Congress to be able
to do that and that's the this is a
rulemaking so you got 60 days of comment
period yep and then it goes into effect
after then we would review the comments
and go to a final rule and then that
could be effective perhaps later this
year but these are things that we can do
while Obamacare is still in place things
that we can do to help make insurance
more affordable at least give options to
people like let's say you lose your job
and you're in oh I don't want ya know I
actually pay for my own honey I'm
actually one of those individual
marketplace purchasers and my insurance
has gone up like 47 percent something
like that's crazy yep so if you lose
your job these kinds of jobs is helpful
for you if somebody else loses yeah
thank you I'm much happier that plants
can be helpful for you as a transition
and to what we've said is these we're
proposing that these plans would be
available for up to 12 months for people
so short-term plans so it could you
hurry up after 12 months or now so we're
actually asking for comment on whether
we could be able whether we have the
legal authority to let people renew
their plans so that's just so that's a
new health alternative so young people
people between jobs middle class people
the the poor people already get covered
they get the Medicaid they get they get
a coverage but it's that group of people
I don't understand they're getting
trashed but you're having fun on your
job I'm loving much you are loving it he
was former general counsel of HHS he was
former Deputy Secretary of HHS former
law clerk Supreme Court former top
executive in business I don't know who
else could be more qualified for this
job but great to see you thanks for
coming on